- Qu'est-ce qui te prend ?
- Rien.
Rien du tout.
Alors c'est ça qu'on fait entre mecs,
on s'ignore ?
Une conversation,
ça pourrait être sympa, non ?
Je peux vous parler
de mon 1er semestre à l'université.
Ou bien...
Derek peut raconter
sa passion pour le camouflage.
Montez les tentes.
Je vais chercher les toilettes.
Les toilettes ? Tu rêves.
Tu m'as comprise.
J'ai besoin d'intimité.
Tu ne trouveras rien ici.
Même pas une cabane ?
Et je fais quoi moi ?
Va dans les bois, comme tout le monde.
J'ai une meilleure idée.
Bernstein, tu me déçois beaucoup.
Quand Craig a dit que tu venais,
j'ai demandé si tu étais prête.
Il a répondu
que tu étais une campeuse émérite.
"Une campeuse émérite ?"
Il a dit ça ?
Tu devrais apprendre à ta copine
à poser une pêche en forêt.
- Pardon ?
- Il est évident que ton université
ne t'a pas préparée au plaisir
de lâcher des bombes anales
dans les grands espaces.
Regarde.
Première étape : creuse un trou.
Deuxième étape :
accroupis-toi et évacue.
Prends ton temps.
Ce n'est pas une course.
Troisième étape,
ma préférée : essuie ton cul
avec ce truc.
Du papier toilette de l'armée,
appelé Alpha Whiskey ou John Wayne.
Quatrième étape : tu retournes au camp,
soulagé et content.
Cinquième étape :
dis au type du papier toilette
de s'occuper de ses affaires.
- Tu n'es qu'une brute.
- Une femme, ça doit apprendre.
Le papier John Wayne ?
Il est dur, rugueux,
et emmerde tout le monde.
- Tu as vu sa tête ?
- Elle voulait me tuer.
Chérie, je reviens demain matin.
Bonjour !
Il y a quelqu'un ?
Si j'étais une clé,
où je me cacherais ?
Tu n'es pas une clé alors tais-toi
et arrête de te parler à toi-même.
Y a-t-il quelqu'un ?
Je ne veux pas vous embêter.
Je campe à côté du lac.
Mais vous vous en fichez
parce que vous n'êtes pas chez vous.
Je me parle encore à moi-même.
Tais-toi.
Un mec est venu nous acheter
une soupape de sûreté
pour son chauffe-eau. Tu vois ?
Mon père lui fait la causette,
tu le connais.
Il a sorti quoi, cette fois ?
Il raconte au type
que tu vas partir en Afghanistan.
Il fait comme si c'était lui,
qui y allait. Tu vois le genre ?
Bon. Et alors...
Le type est à la caisse. Il l'écoute
et lui répond tout doucement :
"Je lui souhaite bonne chance.
Mon fils, lui, n'est pas revenu."
Il a payé et il est parti.
Tu fais chier, mec.
On vient jusqu'ici et toi,
tu me dis ça ?
Je croyais
qu'on était ici pour s'amuser.
Désolé, je disais ça comme ça.
- J'ai pas réfléchi...
- Ah non ?
Je suis désolé
que son fils ne soit pas revenu.
Mais moi, je reviendrai.
Compris ?
Compris.
Je ne me casse pas
au bout du monde pour me faire tuer.
Merde !
- Je vais chercher Tracy.
- Comme tu veux.
Tracy ?
Une fosse septique.
Tu es entrée par effraction !
J'ai la clé. Ils n'en sauront rien,
j'ai laissé la cuvette levée.
Tu ne connais pas ces gens.
Ils pourraient porter plainte.
Pour avoir coulé un bronze ?
Le monde entier n'a pas
les yeux braqués sur toi.
J'ai sauté sur une opportunité.
Tu devrais essayer, une fois. Viens.
Ça s'est bien passé ?
Tracy a trouvé la clé de la maison
et s'est offert le tour du proprio.
Tu es vraiment rentrée ?
Tu as du cran.
Canapé immense,
câble et de vraies toilettes...
Tu rigoles ? On repart là-bas !
Ecoute, je ne sais pas
si j'ai envie de faire l'amour, ce soir.
On n'a pas été très proches
dernièrement.
Que veux-tu que je te dise ?
Tu as voyagé tout l'été.
Moi, je suis resté ici,
à la quincaillerie.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de symétrie.
De symétrie ?
En voilà un mot sérieux.
Alors, tu vas rester ?
Je te l'ai déjà dit.
J'irai à l'université pendant un an.
On verra après ça.
Tu promets ?
Oui... C'est promis.
Et si on partait ?
Non, ça va aller.
La clé ! Maintenant !
Allez ! On y va !
Magnez-vous ! On y va !
- Dépêchez-vous !
- Courez !
Ne t'arrête pas !
Va chercher la clé !
- La ferme ! Je le fais !
- La clé !
Je suis tout trempé !
Sympa.
Je vous l'avais dit.
Super ! Une cheminée !
Ne prends pas trop tes aises.
On se tire après l'orage.
Tu parles d'un romantique !
J'espère que tu assures au lit,
parce qu'habillé, tu crains.
Vous avez faim ?
Regarde ce que tu as fait.
Je regarde, c'est tout.
Je t'ai prévenue. On n'est pas chez toi.
On n'est pas chez toi non plus.
Un feu... Un feu...
Je me suis fait un petit feu...
- Je vais à la douche.
- Tu veux bien arrêter, oui ?
Ce n'est qu'une douche !
Dis ce que tu voudras, mais personne
ne te force à sortir avec elle.
Bon. Où sont ces fameuses toilettes ?
La cave.
Ne m'attends pas.
- Tu fais quoi, là ?
- Je prends une douche.
Pas avec moi.
Ne me regarde pas.
J'ai pris mille kilos cette année.
Sors ! Je ne plaisante pas.
Derek !
Réveille-toi. Les propriétaires.
Habille-toi.
Habille-toi vite ! Allez !
Réveille-toi ! Les propriétaires !
Et merde !
Liz, ne fais pas ça.
Vous sentez ?
Pas de réseau.
20 dollars, ça vous branche ?
Chacun ?
C'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça un "poids mort".
60% du corps est composé de liquide.
J'aurais pu le vider de son sang,
ça l'aurait allégé. Désolé.
Quand j'étais en fac de médecine,
on avait eu un cadavre...
Une femme énorme.
On l'appelait Bertha.
Vous voulez rester petit-déjeuner ?
Abrège ! Tu m'as fait une promesse.
D'accord.
Allez, on continue.
Le but,
c'est que ces gens-là disparaissent.
La vieille garde et les gros bonnets,
ceux qui nous manipulent.
Du sang nouveau !
C'est ça, dont on a besoin.
Sans mauvais jeu de mot.
OK, les gars.
On la met dedans.
Vous vivez ici depuis longtemps ?
J'aime bien la décoration.
Vous l'avez rénovée
ou elle était dans cet état ?
On a besoin de parler ?
On l'a eue à une vente aux enchères.
Le maire a dit qu'elle était abandonnée
depuis des années.
Un scientifique habitait ici.
Il travaillait sur la bombe atomique.
Et les corps, dans la cave ?
Ils étaient vendus avec la maison ?
Est-ce que tu me demandes
si on les a tués ?
Non.
C'est la nature, qui les a tués.
Sans le plastique,
ils moisiront plus vite.
- C'est vous !
- Pas du tout.
Ils étaient faibles. Nous sommes forts.
- Saute.
- Tu seras payée.
Saute dans le trou.
Je ne suis pas idiote.
La ferme et saute !
Saute !
Courez !
Avancez ! Allez !
Suis-le !
Lâche-moi !
Frank ! A l'aide !
Les fenêtres ! Fermez-les !
Vous l'avez vu ? C'était mon sosie.
Le bateau. Où sont les clés ?
La femme, Liz.
Elle les a prises avec elle.
On va mourir.
- Il ne va rien nous arriver.
- C'est pas vrai.
Ils vont revenir et nous tuer.
Elle a raison.
Je ne sais pas qui ils sont,
mais il faut qu'on dégage.
Tu es taré ? Je ne sors pas d'ici.
Comment ça, c'était ton sosie ?
Tu ne les as pas vus ?
Ils étaient trois.
Deux mecs et une fille.
Non. Ils étaient deux : Frank et Liz.
Non, trois. Ils sont sortis
de nulle part et ils étaient nus.
Ils ont descendu le couple.
N'importe quoi.
Mec, j'invente rien, là.
Les trois autres nous ressemblaient
comme deux gouttes d'eau.
Une minute...
Ils étaient nus ?
Salut ! Il y a quelqu'un ?
Tracy ? Derek ?
C'est moi, Craig.
On s'est occupés du couple infernal.
Ils ne vous embêteront plus.
Je sais que tout ça a l'air bizarre.
On va rester dehors un moment,
et vous laisser vous remettre
de vos émotions. D'accord ?
Ah oui, Craig, un petit conseil :
n'appelle pas les flics.
Tu sais ce qui se passe
quand ils voient un cadavre.
Qu'est-ce que tu as ?
Il a lu dans mes pensées.
A la mort de ma mère,
les flics pensaient à un accident.
- Ils avaient tort.
- Tu penses qu'il le savait ?
Ils savent quoi d'autre ?
Tu vois quelque chose ?
Oh, que oui.
Salut. Craig Carlson.
Vous connaissez les autres.
On connaît vraiment un homme
quand on porte son caleçon.
Tu as grossi.
Je n'ai pas besoin de son caleçon
pour connaître ce mec.
On ne t'a jamais dit
que tu avais une tête de cul ?
- Répète.
- Une tête de cul et d'ignare aussi.
Messieurs, enfin !
On peut essayer de s'entendre ?
Derek, excuse-toi.
Mes excuses.
Non, pas ça.
Je ne suis pas curieuse de nature,
mais j'aimerais savoir qui tu es
et d'où tu viens.
D'où je viens ? Tu ne le sais pas ?
Non. Tu m'éclaires ?
Je ne m'en souviens pas vraiment.
Super ton short !
Un peu court, par contre.
On va faire du nettoyage, dehors.
On se fait un petit-déj' ensuite ?
Je te fais confiance
pour élaborer le menu.
Tu vas cuisiner pour la famille Manson ?
Moi, je me tire ailleurs.
Attends.
Pars pas. On ne sait pas
encore ce qui se passe.
Moi, je le sais.
Ces trucs, ces duplicatas,
ils vont revenir et ils vont
nous descendre. Aujourd'hui ou demain.
Et ta solution,
c'est de prévenir la police ?
"Monsieur l'agent,
des personnes qui ont nos visages
et nos empreintes, ont tué des gens."
Je ramerai lentement
si vous changez d'avis.
Attends, attends !
Regarde ! Tu avais raison. Il s'en va.
Tu vois ? Je me connais bien.
Tu penses que tu vas revenir ?
Hé ! Attends-moi !
Doucement, Buce Lee.
On joue dans la même équipe.
Oublie ce que j'ai dit avant.
Je faisais exprès devant les autres.
Je suis avec toi.
Penses-y.
On travaille pour eux,
et ils nous paient au lance-pierre.
Ce ne sont pas nos amis.
Ce que j'essaie de te dire,
c'est que tu mérites mieux.
Je veux t'aider à l'obtenir.
Pauvre con.
On fait quoi, là ?
Aucune idée. Mais ça refroidit.
Et si Derek avait raison ?
S'ils voulaient nous tuer ?
Je ne les laisserai pas faire.
Je n'ai pas de réponse à ta question.
Vous êtes ici, et nous aussi.
Mais je suis sûr
qu'il y a une bonne raison.
Tu n'es pas curieux ?
Ça n'arrive pas tous les jours.
J'espère bien.
Sinon les choses pourraient
tourner mal, sur la côte.
Tu lis nos pensées ?
Non et je n'en ai aucune envie.
Nous avons le même passé ?
Les mêmes souvenirs ?
Disons qu'on vous connaît bien.
Et on est assez déçus.
Ce n'est pas leur faute.
On commet tous des erreurs.
Comme son pote, qui se sert
dans la caisse du magasin de son père ?
Ce genre d'erreur ?
Tu mens.
Derek ne ferait jamais ça.
Calme-toi, Craig.
On n'est pas là pour te juger.
Et pour mettre tout le monde d'accord,
les quincailleries, c'est pas mon truc.
Le mien non plus.
Je préfère encore trucider quelqu'un.
- Vous allez faire quoi ?
- J'en sais rien.
Se la couler douce,
réfléchir à l'avenir du monde.
C'était pas votre but ?
Non. Elle est venue
pour rompre avec lui.
Elle a rencontré un beau gosse à la fac.
Craig, ne les écoute pas.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Si. Elle se le tape
depuis la Fête du Travail.
Mais pour qui tu te prends ?
Reste en dehors de ma vie.
Il ne représentait rien pour moi.
J'allais te le dire.
Je fais quoi, moi ?
Sois toi-même.
Et arrête de me demander ça.
Je peux rester avec toi ?
Je ne mords pas...
fort.
J'y suis allée un peu fort
avec ta copine.
Elle l'a bien vu.
La vérité, c'est que je suis jalouse.
Je ne plaisante pas.
Elle est intelligente,
belle...
Et elle t'a, toi.
Mais le mec de sa fac...
Ce n'était qu'une passade.
- Mais tu as dit...
- C'était des conneries.
Je t'ai dit. Je suis jalouse.
Pourquoi ? Vous êtes les mêmes.
Pas complètement.
On est plutôt comme des cousines.
Sauf qu'elle a les bons gènes.
Et moi, les mauvais.
Une petite baignade ?
J'ai trouvé ce bouquin.
C'est une édition rare sur l'inventeur
de la bombe atomique.
L'auteur fait mention
d'un scientifique du nom de E. Turney.
Il y a une photo.
Dr E. Turney dans son labo.
Brewster Island, 1945.
Attends...
C'est ici.
On est sur Brewster Island.
Liz a dit que cette maison
avait appartenu à un scientifique.
Liz ?
La femme dont vous vous êtes occupés.
Ils l'ont achetée aux enchères.
Elle était abandonnée depuis des années.
Donc si nous sommes dans la maison,
alors où est le labo ?
On a trouvé un truc.
Le labo !
Il faisait partie de la propriété,
mais il a brûlé en 1957.
On sait où il était ?
Non... Ça ne va pas ?
Si, ça va.
Vraiment.
C'est quoi, ça ?
Ça m'étonnerait qu'il soit là.
Là-bas !
Ce doit être ça.
Pourquoi construire un labo
dans un coin paumé ?
Parfait pour une expérience.
Quelle sorte d'expérience ?
Le gouvernement payait les scientifiques
pour construire la bombe atomique.
A part les pièces qu'ils construisaient,
ils ignoraient tout du projet.
Comme des consultants ?
Comment tu le sais ?
En classe, j'écoutais.
On se voit à la maison.
- Il ne s'est rien passé.
- Je m'en fiche.
Tu sais ce qui m'intrigue ?
Tes amis... Ils n'ont pas l'air
d'avoir une once de curiosité.
Ils ne voient pas
qu'ils ont été créé ici.
Mes amis ?
Oui, ils t'apprécient.
J'aurais dû suivre, en cours de chimie.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
C'est étrange.
Le fil électrique va directement
dans la maison.
Tu aurais une lampe torche ?
Un bâton lumineux ?
Il y a un autre labo sous celui-ci.
Ils arrivent.
Alors on est d'accord :
ce soir, quand ils se couchent.
Ça me va.
On devrait attendre.
Quoi ? Qu'ils nous tuent ?
Tracy est amoureuse.
Fais attention, tu as de la compétition.
On devrait leur dire.
Leur expliquer.
Qu'ils sont inférieurs
et qu'ils doivent disparaître ?
Du nouveau ?
Je vais me baigner.
Tu viens ?
- L'eau est glacée.
- Je te tiendrai chaud.
Sans problème.
Tu vas où, mec ?
Tu peux le finir, si tu veux.
Je ne sais pas dessiner.
C'est vrai ?
Je chante mal aussi.
Vous êtes différents tous les deux.
Pardon de te décevoir.
Je ne suis pas déçue.
J'ai hâte de découvrir
qui tu es vraiment.
Elle est gelée !
Tu disais vrai.
Je me réchauffe. Comment tu fais ça ?
J'ai le sang chaud. Touche-moi.
J'étais sérieuse.
Je pensais ce que j'ai dit.
Tracy ne dirait jamais ça.
Je répète : je ne suis pas elle.
Tu me fais tourner la tête...
C'est fait exprès ?
Qu'est-ce que tu lui trouves ?
A ton copain ?
Ce n'est pas mon copain.
Tu couches avec lui.
Il assure, au lit ?
Il embrasse bien ?
Aussi bien que toi ?
Tu dis ça à cause d'elle.
Je ne suis pas elle.
Je ne suis pas ton copain.
Trouve-toi une meilleure copine.
Tu sais ce que je veux.
Comment j'étais ?
Quoi ?
J'étais mieux que lui ?
- Tire-toi.
- Je veux savoir. Pas toi ?
Non, je m'en fous. Tire-toi.
Non. Tu dois d'abord me dire
si j'étais meilleur que lui.
Menteuse !
Je t'aime beaucoup, Tracy.
Mais tu n'as pas d'ambition.
Tu ne veux pas être la meilleure.
Etre le meilleur n'est pas si important.
D'accord, tu as une super technique.
Supérieure à la sienne.
Mais quel est l'intérêt,
si après tu te comportes comme un con ?
Les noms propres, abréviations,
préfixes et suffixes sont interdits,
de même que les mots
utilisant un tiret ou une apostrophe.
Vous devriez utiliser
des mots à la racine étrangère,
ainsi que des mots archaïques,
obsolètes,
du jargon familier et argotique.
C'est ironique, non ?
Les filles nettoient
et les garçons jouent.
Des années de fac pour ça...
Craigie, tu as tiré le plus gros numéro.
Tu commences.
Survivre.
Tu l'aimes ?
Il a l'air de t'apprécier.
Qui ça ? Craig ? Il est adorable.
Il n'y a rien à redire.
Mais tu sais...
Non. Quoi ?
Il n'accomplira jamais rien d'important.
" Eudaimonia ."
Ça signifie "bien-être".
Par exemple, j'éprouve  eudaimonia
parce que je gagne,
et que tu es heureuse pour moi.
" Eudaimonia ", ça me plaît.
Alors, tu es "eudémoniste".
Ça va ?
C'est leur petit jeu,
de faire qu'on se sente bêtes.
On l'est peut-être.
Il suffit de regarder
leur plateau de jeu.
Plus cultivés, peut-être.
Mais pas forcément plus intelligents.
Tu admires leur génie et leur audace.
Moi aussi.
Mais c'est toi, que je préfère.
Sans problème.
Derek avait raison.
On devrait partir. Ce soir.
Mais d'abord,
allons jeter un œil au labo.
Je ne pensais pas ce que j'ai dit.
J'ai fait ça pour
qu'elle soit moins méfiante.
Vous en faites trop,
tous les trois.
Je ne te ferai jamais de mal. Crois-moi.
Je suis tombée amoureuse de toi.
S'ils l'apprennent, ils me tueront.
Promets que tu ne diras rien.
Ce sera notre secret.
Elle a été prise dans le sud.
Ce semestre.
Elle t'a menti.
J'ai réfléchi et
tout ça a forcément un lien avec le labo.
C'est de là que viennent les clones.
Mais comment notre ADN a atterri là-bas ?
De quoi tu parles ?
Nos doubles.
Ils viennent de nous, mais comment ?
J'ai repensé à l'autre Craig.
Comment il fixait la fosse sceptique.
Il essayait de se souvenir.
Et puis ça m'est venu.
Clair comme de l'eau de roche.
Si tout ça est vrai,
pourquoi il n'y en a pas plus ?
De doubles.
Tu vas au toilettes
toutes les 20 minutes.
C'est pas vrai !
Il doit y avoir un élément déclencheur.
C'est peut-être l'orage ? La foudre ?
Peut-être.
Mets ça.
C'est bon ?
Donne-moi les bâtons.
Je croyais que tu restais à la fac.
Craig, pas maintenant.
Je veux savoir.
On en parlera plus tard.
Promis.
Allez.
- J'entends rien.
- Ils le font peut-être comme ça.
J'oubliais... Elle doit le savoir.
Tracy ? Craigie ? Tout va bien ?
Ses rapports d'étude.
Le scientifique.
Il se lance dans cette expérience
"pas pour faire avancer l'humanité,
mais pour la recréer."
"Le 10 mai 1957.
"Expression des gènes
plus régulière dans échantillon 205.
"Profil de méthylation à recalibrer."
"15 juin. Cellule améliorée...
"...dans le métabolisme
de l'échantillon 222."
"Traces de progéria éliminées..."
"Reçu : lettre de l'Académie
me refusant les fonds supplémentaires.
"Ce sont eux, que je devrais remplacer."
Regarde !
"20 juin. Technique revisitée.
Derniers échantillons prometteurs.
"Problème : manque de confiance en soi.
"L'homme se bat pour prouver sa valeur.
Quel qu'en soit le prix."
Viens soir.
"10 septembre 1957.
"Maturité à terme dans échantillon 229
sans amoindrissement des fonctions.
"Signe évident de vie ?"
"5 octobre.
"Le monde est captivé par
le lancement de Spoutnik.
"Que pensera-t-il de ma découverte ?"
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Tracy, arrête.
Ses dernières notes,
celles sur son "annonce"...
Il préparait quelque chose.
Il avait fini son expérience.
Créer une armée de robots ?
Pas de robots.
De clones.
Des reproductions humaines.
C'est lui ! Docteur Turney.
Regarde, le numéro de ses notes.
Il est vide.
C'est moi, du calme.
Tu fais quoi ici ?
Moi ? Et lui, c'est qui ?
Je t'expliquerai.
Les fourbes...
Ils disaient n'avoir rien trouvé.
- Turney a été tué par sa création ?
- On peut le prouver.
- Et son tueur, il est où ?
- Je ne sais pas. Il a dû fuir.
Allons-y.
Salut ! Vous m'entendez ?
Ce n'est pas drôle ! Ouvre la porte !
Tu viens de m'appeler
par mon prénom. Je suis flatté.
Ouvre-nous, tas de merde.
C'est ça, ton vrai nom.
Derek, tu es revenu. C'est...
vraiment nase.
Mais tu es nase, alors...
Sans rancune.
Foncez à la maison.
Rapportez de quoi faire du feu.
Gaz à briquet, dissolvant, tissus...
- Vous me suivez ?
- A fond.
Tu veux faire quoi ?
Je saisis ma chance.
Il y a une autre sortie ?
- On n'en a pas vue.
- Il y a quoi, dans ton sac ?
Vous êtes encore là ?
Pour un mec aussi intelligent,
tu es vraiment bête.
Pourquoi ça ?
Ton énorme cerveau a oublié
la case "curiosité".
C'est super nul, au lit ou en dehors.
C'est quoi ?
Une fusée éclairante.
Pour faire signe aux bateaux.
Quoi ? On ne sait jamais.
Un pistolet lance-fusées.
Pas bête, ta meuf.
J'ai trouvé ça.
Elle a un problème ?
Tu veux dire aujourd'hui ?
Je veux que tu me dises la vérité.
Tu as pris de l'argent dans la caisse ?
Pardon ?
- Quelqu'un m'a dit ça.
- Qui ?
Tu le crois ?
Ils savent tout sur nous.
Je me suis dit...
Tu t'es dit quoi ?
Je travaille dur au magasin.
Ton père le sait bien.
- Tu réponds à côté.
- Si je suis un voleur ?
Les mecs...
Je veux savoir.
Tu as pris l'argent ou non ?
J'en avais besoin
et ça me gênait de demander.
Je suis désolé.
Tu allais partir sans me le dire.
Comme elle.
Il t'arrive quoi ?
C'est quoi, le problème ?
Il est complètement inférieur à nous.
A toi, peut-être.
Il ne te mérite pas.
Et toi, oui ?
Tout est prêt.
Tu as 30 secondes pour choisir ton camp.
Eh, les filles ! Vous êtes encore là ?
Pas pour longtemps, face d'hémorroïde !
Regardez ! Vos permis de conduire.
Quoi ?
Vous auriez refusé de nous les donner.
- Je vous ai dit qu'il nous tuerait !
- Ça t'étonne ?
C'était soit vous, soit nous.
Non. On n'est pas des tueurs.
Tu es sûre ?
Au revoir, Tracy.
J'ai été ravi de te rencontrer.
Prépare-toi.
Aux abris !
Avancez ! Allez !
Ça va ?
Il y a des pièces secrètes.
Cherche une faille ou une porte.
C'est quelque part par ici.
Ici !
Je vois un truc.
Bougez-vous ! On y va !
Regardez ! Le produit s'écoule
par les canalisations.
C'est comme ça qu'il s'est répandu.
On verra ça plus tard.
Ah ! Bon sang !
Il a été brûlé.
Va chercher de quoi le soigner.
Calme-toi. Là...
On est sous la maison !
Ecoutez.
- C'est grave ?
- Assez.
- On les a eus ? Les "inférieurs" ?
- Ne t'inquiète pas. On les a eus.
Tu leur as fait quoi ?
Ils ont essayé de le tuer.
On n'a pas eu le choix.
Il est blessé.
Bien fait.
On va te sortir d'ici.
La clé du bateau.
Fais-le.
Je fais quoi avec ça ?
Je coule un bronze ?
Sers t'en contre eux !
Je ne tue personne. C'est ton job.
Alors abandonne et rends-toi à eux.
Ils ont essayé de nous tuer.
Ils recommenceront.
On pourrait faire un marché ?
Ils prennent les lundis,
mardis et mercredis ?
- Tu parles de meurtre ?
- Je te parle de survie.
On peut s'exiler et changer d'identité.
C'est impossible
parce que j'adore ma vie.
Je suis prêt à me battre pour elle.
Pas vous ?
Un jour, tu me remercieras.
Pour quoi ?
Papa ! c'est moi !
Non. Ça va super.
On va revenir un jour plus tôt.
Voilà, demain. Dis, tu peux le dire...
à la mère de Tracy ?
Tu l'appelles et tu lui dis ?
Derek te passe le bonjour.
Pas mal.
On ne peut pas les laisser faire.
On doit les arrêter.
J'ai une idée.
On verse l'eau dans la bouteille.
Ça active le sac de chaleur.
La bouteille enfle.
Boom ! C'est prêt. Un RPE.
Un Repas Prêt à Exploser.
Et la sauce piquante ?
Du gaz lacrymogène.
Ce bijou a deux minutes
devant lui avant d'exploser.
Ça va marcher ?
Tiens.
C'est officiel. Mlle Bernstein.
Dans tous les combats,
on meurt s'il y a trop de stratégie.
Alors soyez prêts à improviser.
Il nous faut un code
pour qu'on se reconnaisse.
Des suggestions ?
Marco.
Polo.
Parfait.
On fait un trio de choc.
Ceux d'en face aussi.
On reste fidèle au plan.
Il ne faut pas éveiller les soupçons.
On joue les abrutis ?
Ils le verront. On va se faire choper.
Comment ?
En étant plus malins ?
Détends-toi.
Nos parents vont nous adorer.
On est partis !
Elle m'a vu.
- L'autre Tracy.
- Quoi ?
Elle a fait quoi ?
Rien.
C'est quoi ce bruit ?
Quoi ?
- Merde !
- C'est quoi ?
Eteins ou je la tue.
Eteins !
Ne lui fais pas de mal.
Tu ne comprends pas.
Je ne voulais pas
qu'ils te fassent du mal.
- Ce n'est pas toi.
- Maintenant, si.
Je suis ébahi. Comme tu as changé !
Ton attitude, ta confiance.
On dirait presque moi.
Je ne veux pas être comme toi.
Tu ne veux pas vivre.
C'est fou, mec.
On fait quoi ?
- La ferme !
- Ce n'est pas notre combat.
Notre combat est là-bas,
contre ces gens,
qui nous rabaissent.
Qui nous gardent sous contrôle.
Qui nous culpabilisent
quand on prend ce qui est à nous.
Si papa était là,
il dirait la même chose, non ?
Tu mérites mieux que ça, frère.
Mieux que ce qu'un uniforme
peut t'apporter.
Recule. Je te préviens !
Ce n'est que moi.
Qui te connaît le mieux ?
Tu ne me connais pas.
Oh que si !
Pauvre con.
- Il lui est arrivé quoi ?
- Il a essayé de fuir.
Je le croyais plus rapide.
Tu aurais dû m'écouter.
- Demande-lui.
- Attends.
Je connais un type. Marco.
Quoi ?
- Marco, tu te souviens ?
- Je ne vois pas.
Bordel, tu fais quoi là ?
Tu ne piges rien du tout.
Tracy avait raison.
Pour quelqu'un de si intelligent,
tu es vraiment bête.
C'est impossible.
On est plus forts, plus malins...
Plus malins ? Que qui ?
Que vous tous, les "inférieurs" !
Il y a un proverbe
que tu devrais apprendre.
"Heureux les débonnaires,
car ils hériteront de la terre."
Tu as eu ta chance.
C'est notre tour.
A l'aide.
A l'aide !
Il faut l'aider.
Derek, c'est moi. Je faisais semblant.
Marco, c'est ça ? Marco !
Craig ! J'ai dit Marco !
Polo.
De Ralph Lauren.
Le lac !
On est là ! Attends ! Attends !
Il faut en être sûrs.
Tracy, j'ai dit Marco.
Polo.
On va toujours au concert ?
C'est 30 dollars ?
Ne t'inquiète pas. Je t'invite.
J'ai une meilleure idée.
Viens chez moi. Mon père est de sortie.
- Téléphone.
- Bonjour, M. Carlson.
Je reviens.
- Tu vas bien ?
- Oui, et toi ?
C'est moi, Tracy.
Ne raccroche pas.
Tu dois me croire.
Marco.
Adaptation : Julie Lespourcy